they have been here for a week blocking
roads to protest the Detention of their
governor Luis Fernando Camacho
he was taken to Bolivia's Capital La Paz
last week a accused of plotting to
overthrow former president Evo Morales
in 2019.
we won't allowed that this government
installs a dictatorship in the country
they have detained our governor and we
will be on the roads defending him
Santa Cruz is an opposition stronghold
a rich region that plays a crucial role
in Bolivia's economy
the Detention of Governors
the highlands and the province of Santa
Cruz that's located in the lowlands of
this country people have been coming
here to the center of the city steadily
every night to demand the release of
their governor and confronting with the
police
the police use tear gas and rubber
bullets to control the protesters dozens
have been detained
Camacho is currently kept in a high
security detention center in La Paz he's
on pre-trial detention for four months
while the investigation is ongoing
on Wednesday the prison was surrounded
by the red ponchos indigenous government
supporters who wanted to prevent Camacho
followers from reaching the area
we are protesting because since Congress
members from Santa Cruz are arriving we
want Luis Fernando Camacho to stay in
for 30 years
Camacho is not the only member of the
opposition detained former interim
president Johnny nanez was sentenced to
10 years in prison she was on pre-trial
detention for over one year
the government insists Camacho and
others were involved in a coup to
overthrow Morales
[Applause]
people from Santa Cruz say they were
defending the country's democracy from
the fraud committed by Morales during
the presidential elections in 2019.
in 2019 there was a vacuum of power even
Morales resigned Janine and yes assumed
as president and she was recognized by
Congress the so-called coup is their
excuse to persecute political opponents
and that's why thousands are vowing to
remain on the streets challenging the
national government that they claim is
not respecting the rule of law
Bolivia